Hello friends. This is Emily, joining you from my New York state bedroom.
As you can tell, I'm wearing sunglasses.
This is all because of a new fashion trend that I've recently started called,...
..."Wear your sunglasses at all times,...
...look cool and feel great." Heck, yeah!
In any case, I've been up to so much since I've been in New York.
I've been just, just doing activities that I would have never dreamt of doing anywhere else in the world.
Because when you're in Western New York, everything is possible.
And I've been doing everything, ever.
So, I decided to compile some clips today.
You know, compile some clips to show you guys what I've been up to...
...because I know you've been missing me.
I mean, I've gotten just thousands of e-mails in the past minute...
...of people just begging me to make a new video clip.
And what can I say, I like to give.
Not take, but give.
So I'm gonna give to you by just compiling clips as I said previously and just showing them.
So, I hope you can enjoy watching me in what I've been doing.
I'm gonna narrate these clips I suppose.
I'm all about narration.
So, anyway, I hope you enjoy and keep it real.
Wow! Pool rocks.
Yes!
It's broken!
It works!
I can't play the guitar at all.
And it's so sad!
I'm so sweet at playing the drums.
Yes!
So, I hope you've enjoyed watching these clips...
...as much as I've enjoyed compiling them and showing them to you.
Remember, the word of the day is 'Compile'.
And until we meet again, you know, keep it real,...
...keep it intense, and you know, keep it damn stylish.